the head of the house committee
investigating the assault on the capitol
confirms to cbs news that the trump
administration discussed an idea to have
the military seize voting machines from
the 2020 election he also told face the
nation that the committee has questioned
former attorney general william barr who
resigned after the election under cloudy
circumstances nicole killian looks at
the new evidence pointing to a
widespread effort to overturn the
election results
on face the nation select committee
chairman benny thompson revealed former
attorney general william barr who left
the trump administration weeks before
january 6 talked to the panel we are
concerned
that our military
was part of this big
on promoting
that the election was false the chairman
referenced a draft executive order from
december 2020 first reported by politico
that would have authorized the defense
secretary to seize collect retain and
analyze all voting machines and allowed
the appointment of a special counsel the
order was never enacted and it was one
of the documents former president
trump's lawyers allegedly tried to
shield from congressional investigators
so if you are using the military
to potentially seize
voting machines even though it's a
discussion
the public needs to know do you have
proof that there was someone inside the
united states military
working on this premise
of actually seizing voting machines
between the department of justice a plan
uh was put forward
to potentially seize voting machines in
the country and utilize
department of defense assets
to make that happen in december of 2020
barr in an interview with the associated
press said the department of justice did
investigate voter fraud connected to the
2020 election but concluded to date we
have not seen fraud on a scale that
could have affected a different outcome
in the election weeks later barr
resigned just a month shy before trump's
term ended
the committee is pouring over hundreds
of documents that were recently released
by the national archives so far the
panel has interviewed about 400
witnesses and hopes to hold public
hearings this spring
nicole thank you very much